I only have many things in film Bob's
new suit one of which is recovery and
people you know going one way their
lives and then changing weather through
having a sponsor or being in 12-step
program whatever can you tell us more
about incorporating that into your story
what I tried to do with the construction
of the movie was to weave together
multiple stories and stories that
reflected the community in which we all
live here in Southern California and
Bob's girlfriend Jenny is in recovery
she is clean and sober she does have a
history of addiction her mother is a
drinking alcoholic who in the course of
the movie does find recovery and I'm
simply trying to reflect part of the
world I live in I have been in recovery
for a very very long time and so it's
part of my life
was the decision to put some of the
recovery community into the script an
initial decision as part of what you'd
always envisioned for the movie or
because it came together so quickly it
was something that was decided on set I
mean how much in progress oh no there
was virtually no improv it was a written
screenplay you know there were always
adjustments in shooting but there was no
no there was no real improv and the way
that I work is that that things come to
me as I'm sitting there at the computer
I was working on the character of
Stephanie Bob sister and I was writing a
scene and I knew Oh Stephanie is really
Steve Stephanie's going to stephanie's a
transgender and that there were no
decisions in advance of what I would
cover or not cover in the script they
literally come out of me and I weave
them together as they arrived in my
doorstep and where do you get these
ideas I personally Julia Cameron talks
about they'll happen while she's driving
different different people have
different sort of areas that these Julie
Cameron's a friend of mine oh okay yeah
and yes they come whenever when driving
at the computer during of somebody
else's movie watching junk television
exercising any time they just come as
leaves to the tree that's their organic
and they simply arrive
you